elizabeth what's going on well i am a
mother of two adopted
kids three and six oh
you are egg wait let's pause right there
you're in it
yep you're super in it right
yeah open or closed adoptions uh
closed okay so you're super super super
in it are you married
yes okay and um ever since
we adopted these girls as they came into
our lives
we've my husband and i have not been
intimate so i feel like we're a roommate
okay and then i i'm a teacher also
so with covet and everything i'm like my
job duties have like doubled
so i kind of feel stressed and
frustrated with everything and everyone
yeah and i find myself yelling at my
girls and
i just um i don't
like don't know how to be the um
christian mother and wife that i want to
be in my situation
that sucks i'm sorry
i just i hate all that for you i know
it's exhausting man and
being on an island by yourself sucks and
i'm sorry um
when did the girls come home did they
come together
no yeah they're they're siblings okay
they came same time
how long have they been there uh
three years now so you and your husband
haven't slept together for three years
no tell me about that
what was that off switch that happened
when you brought the girls home
i i honestly i don't know i
asked my husband about it and he said
well we've got two
little ones in the house or yeah or so
tired
and you know um that's basically
about the just of it you know
what was your relationship like before
you brought these kids home
i'd say it was it was pretty good um
you know i mean i was a stepmother
to two sons and then they grew up
and left the house and um so
i don't know um the conflicts with
uh how he disciplined them but since he
was their biological
you know father uh he did you know
basically all of the disciplining
and um so
i don't i don't know i mean i guess i
really should aspire and
we we have a lot of agreements on things
like
um my spiritual beliefs
and we enjoy reading um
but we don't have a lot in common other
than that i guess
and how old are you how old am i 62.
52. and my husband's 61. 61.
okay have y'all
the pursuits you talked about were all
cognitive
they're all informational we like to put
information
into the front of our brains together
other than that we don't have a lot and
so what i'll tell you
is other people who share
the joy of shoving information into the
front of their brains are
you know professional colleagues and
like you mentioned
roommates and people who sit next to
each other in college classes
right not husbands and wives right
have y'all ever gone to see somebody
we did and um he basically
said well you know it's really you that
needs to see a counselor
and so i just automatically stopped it
so you and your husband went and saw a
counselor and then he after seeing a
counselor he looked at you and said
you're the one with the problems
pretty much yeah okay like you're the
one that needs to go to counseling and i
just
i said okay so we're not going because
if we don't if
two people you know are in agreement
with needing counseling it's not gonna
not gonna help so
yes you can't go three years without
having sex in your marriage
particularly if one of you is dying on
the vine i'm telling you something you
don't know right you know this
um
the way you keep yourself staved off
from burnout
the way you keep yourself engaged
relationally the way
you keep your heart and mind tethered in
is
when you are fully connected when you
are fully known
when you are intimate with somebody
intimacy doesn't always have to be sex
okay but intimate can be
we turn all the sound off in the house
and we sit down and talk to one another
every single night and we hold hands
every single day and yeah sexual
intimacy is a big
part of that and we i wake up every day
with a desired how can i make his life
better what are ways that i can show up
for what he needs and he wakes up with
that same thought about you
right and if you don't have that man
there your you're end up being an
untethered
with everything you try to do and you
throw on top of that two
adopted baby girls who are adjusting to
all the trauma they've experienced
and they're all over your house i can't
even imagine
i'm younger than you and i've got a
five-year-old and every day i think
i'm gonna sleep for the rest of my life
starting right now right i can't imagine
how tired you guys are
at the same time that connection and
that intimacy is what fuels that
everything does that make sense yeah um
so here's where i'm going to disagree
with you
if your husband's not willing to go get
well he's got some
challenges okay there's something
happened of some sort of
what i would call major significance
that you brought home these two girls
and a switch flipped off in your home
and i'd have to spend some time with you
both directly
to really root that out and that's not
my job here
but there's man this just smells uh
reeks of major trauma somewhere this
week's of something
major have has there ever been
infidelity in your home
no does your husband have a history of
abuse no
do you no i don't hit him no
no no no not not each other has people
ever hurt you in y'all's past
no okay um man there is something else
here
and it will exceed the scope of this of
this radio show
here's what i'm gonna disagree with you
on i'm gonna challenge you okay
um okay at the end of the day you can't
make him do anything right
right what you can do is learn some new
skills
work on you and so i think that in this
situation
i can't recommend more than enough if
i'm you i'd be on the call on the phone
today going to see somebody i'd be on
the phone today reaching out saying i
want to see somebody
i'm literally suffocating from
loneliness um
let a therapist know i am i am
truly interested in being intimate with
my husband and we haven't slept together
in three years
i've got two adopted young girls that
are driving us all ragged
and i've gotta i've gotta be well and
whole and um
start working on yourself that's the
best you can do
five years from now you're gonna be five
years later right so you're 52 you're
gonna be 57 anyway
you can be 57 and have an 11 year old
and what a seven year old and be
further exhausted and further withered
out on that vine or
you can learn some more things about
yourself you can learn some new skills
you can at some point possibly model for
your husband what it looks like
and he's going to want to join you or he
may just opt out
he may just flat opt out but your
marriage
is on life support right now um you need
one another in a
significant major way there's some other
stuff here like i keep saying
um and you need to take the first step
because why not because what
i mean what else you got to take the
first step um yeah elizabeth you got to
go go go go
um when it comes to being a teacher and
all that there's a lot of resources
all of these resources stacked on top of
a foundation
of of a home
marriage that's got a such a crack in it
as yours does isn't gonna help
so go get yourself whole go get yourself
well start learning new things
um process this as a trauma that it is
and then be about hey how do i deal with
burnout at work how do i
become a better mom to these kids et
cetera
ah i'm heartbroken for you i hate it for
you i hate it for you elizabeth
go today and make that call go today